muy Thai Muay Thai Thai boxing more time
now never heard of that nope you're so
you're so what are you white yeah you're
also like a non jock well I was a jock
my whole life what would you do I played
a football did you oh that's right I
played football forever and tracking a
bunch of stuff then you fuck like then I
stopped did you flick your body up at
all no not too bad
my shoulders a little bit and my
shoulders a little but that's pretty
much it my knees you know like I run a
lot now I've been running a lot for the
last couple months and uh what just want
to be in better shape yeah I want to
feel better I drop like burn off some
rounds maybe yeah it looks good that's
all thanks man that's a cool thing once
you get going right yeah at that
momentum that's what's up well you know
it's really was up was I was kind of
cruising along and just like lost 5
pounds just kind of like hanging around
and then I realized I'm working out like
this workout that I'm doing is would
have it'll warm up when I was an athlete
like this wouldn't even have been a
warm-up and I'm like oh that was pretty
good stop being a sissy and try and
really push it a little more what'd you
get a trainer yeah I don't like intimacy
well you know yeah else you can do
there's actually apps where you can
follow an app and the app will put you
through a workout oh yeah yeah there's
several of them now they're really good
oh cool a bunch of really good ones I
don't have any affiliation with any of
them so you're not naming any of them
but yeah you can um you can even get a
yoga one you get a 90-minute yoga one
where I just do yoga and it would talks
you through the poses it's great yeah I
used to do yoga all the time but I feel
like I've got it I feel I have to shift
into lifting weights again yeah it's
been dropping notes but I just feel like
you know a little bit I don't want to be
like at the pool with no arms you know I
mean so many people have motivated them
something
by going to the beach or the pool with
very little clothes on I thought about
Fox summertime
fuck people are gonna know reveal my
secret know what disgusts me about yeah
this is my gluttony look at it
this is my laziness look this is what I
did all winter this is my poor food
choices right here look this is drinking
yes upper upper part yeah this is the
part right on the sides but I really
just but then when I started getting
after and being like don't be such a
sissy like workout right try and push it
then you want it then I wanted to do it
more then I got into it then I'm like
alright let's go now I'm going further
I'm going quicker but uh this is all
been cardio yeah all cardio what about
just body weight stuff like you know I
mean it's not a bad idea to start off
with body weight first of all chefs yeah
because you haven't really done much
like that in a while
yeah it's chin ups push ups and the
bodyweight squats really don't need much
else really not really I've been doing
more push-ups demons a ferocious workout
in with change grip push-ups chin-ups
bodyweight squats just to just those
things does that mean I have to get one
of those chin up bar as it goes in the
doorway that yeah get a real one though
because those things fall and people die
the ones that hang folks listen to me
yeah those ones that hang on the door
the door jamb yeah I used to work
construction those fucking things are
not designed for little tiny nails
people like me probably installed them
and sometimes you don't hit a stud yeah
that little tiny nail is going right
into the fucking drywall yeah and and
you're hanging that thing over there and
it's pulling on that sucker no they
don't mess my shoulder well because the
fuckers that drill into the side of the
door you know what I'm saying I mean the
ones that they go right in the side this
way oh into the gym like four screws on
each side if that'll hold your weight
all right I don't hold your weight I'll
get that that won't work
cuz it's put your pulling down on the
wood yeah the way those things are it's
like sitting on the wood you know those
ones that hold yeah that shit is a
recipe for a broken neck I feel like
that thing was in like every 80s movie
yeah I'm sure they have good ones that
do that I'm sure yeah sure but you
should really check out your fucking
moldings first yes
moldings why'd I just lay on the ground
and do some push-ups
but a real chin up our man a real chin
up bar is I mean if you just got one in
a park just go to the fucking Park
you're outside they'll a lot of parks
have like those yeah bars those little
setups we could do council yes yeah
nobody ever genomes are no joke those
are great for working out I know they
seem too simple you seem like old ladies
would let's go over there bro like order
Nautilus I don't need this right exactly
I do my leg extensions on Nautilus I got
my membership I use once a month
bodyweight squad seem easy when you do
three yeah when you do a hundred they
become very fucking hard right when you
get to like 70 you're like whole shit
you rid of that burn baby and you start
counting down in tens push-ups when I
played football and you do you know 200
would be like 200 you break him on a row
no break come out of you in a row they
would do like 30 mm-hmm and then you
know split them up and you know it was a
big time workout and now I'm doing like
25 I'm like I'm good for a couple days
it's getting anywhere more than 30
push-ups it's like whew just starts
getting crazy yeah a lot of pushing yeah
to like your body has to be conditioned
for that and if it's not it lets you
know your arm starts shaking the
funniest part is hockey around 19 though
you get to like 18 19 like bro I'm
feeling fucked it's smooth it's so funny
how whatever number you have in your
head is where you start to write if you
say I'm doing 20 you start shaking at 18
if you say I'm doing 25 you don't start
shaking until 23 you know it's a real
mental thing